das ist auch ihr gesehen heute abend
nämlich die frage was mit der
sicherheitspolitik in der nächsten
koalition passieren ja absolut ich finde
die ampel die darf jetzt kein grünes
licht geben für eine un-
sicherheitsposition denn das was wir im
moment erleben mit der debatte über
illegale migration wo man eben sie die
antwort soll der spurwechsel seien
bleibe perspektiven statt abschiebungen
das ist aus meiner sicht nur ein erstes
schlaglicht darauf wie stiefmütterlich
die innenpolitik im zweifel in einer
solchen ampel koalition behandelt werden
könnte ich habe debatten erlebt in der
zurückliegenden legislaturperiode
über das bundespolizei gesetz
rechtsgrundlagen für den
verfassungsschutz die debatten darüber
wie gehen wir um zb mit der
vorratsdatenspeicherung zum kampf gegen
kinderpornografie da haben wir erlebt
dass es oft zu große angst vor neuen
befugnissen für unsere
sicherheitsbehörden darf und dass
manches mal dann zu übersteigerte
datenschutz wünsche dazu führen könnten
dass am ende der datenschutz zum
täterschutz wird und das dürfen wir für
diese ampel nichts wissen
wenn ich einen übersteigerten
datenschutz denke denke ich mehr die
union 1 1 die fdp also warum glaubst du
dass vor allem jetzt bei der ampel die
gefahr dafür da ist ja das glaube ich
vor allem deshalb wenn man auf die
konkreten instrumente schaut zb die
vorratsdatenspeicherung da sieht man ja
das war ganz beliebt die fdp hat uns
vorgehalten wie schwimmen dieses
instrument sei wir würden dem bürger aus
forschen wollen für uns war aber immer
klar ohne vorratsdatenspeicherung werden
uns die harten schläge gegen
kinderpornografie ring nicht gelingen
oder die debatte über die sogenannte
online durchsuchungen wir wollten dass
unser verfassungsschutz unsere
bundespolizei bei extremisten bei
schweren gefährdern im durchaus auch
dann analysieren kann datenströme
analysieren kann die antwort von fdp und
anderen war nur der staatstrojaner das
so zur aim und montag offen ich bin
großer fan der fdp wissen alle ich würde
mit ihnen gern zusammenarbeiten
und weil man wohl einmal das große
sorgen wenn die sich jetzt mit rot
kremser wobei man sagen muss der
mutmaßlich nächste kanzler olaf scholz
der ist noch nicht bekannt als jemand
der bei der sicherheitspolitik besonders
zurück wurde vorgeworfen dass in hamburg
brecht mittel eingesetzt wurden in
sieben als innensenator
neben wurde vorgeworfen dass er viel zu
hardliner risch unterwegs und seine
leute sagen das ist genau die politik
von olaf scholz zum einen in richtung
mindestlohn zu gehen soziale
gerechtigkeit aber eben auch bei innerer
sicherheit vater kannte und ich glaube
es kommt doch sehr darauf an wer am ende
nachfolger von horst seehofer war den
man ehrlicherweise in den letzten
monaten oder ich will fast letzten
jahren sagen kaum noch wahrgenommen hat
also ich finde der hätte sich dem
problem an der grenze zum beispiel viel
viel früher annehmen können und viel
härter auf den tisch fallen aber die
entscheidende frage ist doch wer bekommt
das innenministerium und wer ist dann
derjenige der all diese probleme
anpacken ja und die frage ist noch wie
wir aus guter quelle wissen noch nicht
geklärt also insofern ist das noch offen
das erlaubt sowie in der es kaum möglich
sein dass das die fdp bekommt oder
möglicherweise bekommen die amis oder
holen sich das justizministerium das ist
eine offene frage wenn das in ressort an
die fdp ginge wäre das auch sicherlich
ein garant für eine etwas härtere linie
aber die sache ist bayern am tor doch
eigentlich ganz anders ich meine ihnen
muss man zugute halten dass man nicht
wirklich jetzt positiv dass sie 2015
auch nicht im bundestag waren und was
sie jetzt nur eine meiner kern
motivation 2017 zu kandidieren
glückwunsch also eine letzte die grenzen
kann man nicht schützen das hatten glück
und sind sicher sie hat immer durch den
strom verhindern daher
hat auch alles doch nicht auch die cdu
ist auch die cdu nach dem motto
gehandelt macht hoch die tür da gab es
doch überhaupt keine kontrollen im
gegenteil es gab doch die erklärte
bereitschaft auch wir bei bild damals
war ich ja bei bild haben gesagt
referees werk kommt für eine gewisse
zeit aber damals gab es doch die
bereitschaft alle zu nehmen die damals
in ungarn waren sich auf den weg gemacht
haben überhaupt aus den ganzen
flüchtlings gebiet damals und es gab
keine steuerung und es gab keine
kontrollen und es gab im nachhinein auch
keine nachverfolgung der ist aber 2000
sie wollten ihnen maßeinheit für uns ein
hauptthema in der letzten wahlperiode
es war die hockey herren
haben das genutzt aber der satz 2015
darf sich nicht wiederholen ist ja nicht
daher gesagt das ist für uns aber
jährigen kanzlerin hat ein sehr
interessantes interview gegeben am
wochenende in der süddeutschen zeitung
und hat da auch über die
flüchtlingspolitik gesprochen wo man
herauslesen konnte dass sie das vor
allem also so beschreibt sie es daher
aus humanistischen aus humanitären
gründen gemacht hat und sie sagt hat
jeder mensch ist eben wichtig nena wie
hast du das wahrgenommen in der
flüchtlingskrise habe ich das als einen
humanitären akt irischen ausmaßes wagen
also ich bin hier glaube ich komplett
konträr auf jeden fall schon mal zu euch
beiden weil ich sage die union hätte
darauf stolz sein können können wir
brauchen gegen haben sie können worker
nochmals beide sammlungen da bin ich
auch dafür dass wir schnell erfassen
wenn jemand mist hier bald muss er raus
da bin ich auch ab dem 1 aber damals war
das für mich im moment wo ich stolz war
deutsch zu sein wo ich stolz europäerin
zu sein und was werden die andere lösung
gewesen bei den grenzkontrollen das
könntest du ins besser beurteilen sich
deswegen die frage an dich park werden
die besten gefälschten papiere das wäre
doch bestimmt die terroristen er gewesen
als die geflohenen oder die gefälschten
papiere waren tatsächlich in der zeit
muss ich vielleicht kurz aufstellen ich
war dort sehr viel als reporter
unterwegs sowohl in syrien als auch andy
harrison usw die papiere hat man sehr
leicht bekommen ich hab mir auch mal ein
pass machen lassen für 2000 dollar
glaube ich ging das damals so hast du
dann irgendein datum reingepackt und
hass plötzlichen gefälschten fast
bekommen und auch das passiert noch mehr
ehrgeiz wird das erdgas wird er
sicherlich besser wissen das passiert ja
an vielen orten immer noch diese
gefälschten papiere der
urkundenfälschung ist ist ein delikt
womit sich die bundespolizei tagtäglich
beschäftigen mich damals wahrhaft und
wir sehen wahrscheinlich ja ich kann
einen zugang erkannt
aber das ist eben ist genau der punkt
also wir haben sowohl an den flughäfen
als auch im land ganz mit
urkundenfälschung selbstverständlich zu
tun das ist gar keine dank einfacher
aber nicht das kein problem was er sagte
gerade die vorratsdatenspeicherung jena
ich erinnert an den anschlag vom
breitscheidplatz 2016 in berlin hätten
wir da eine anständige
vorratsdatenspeicherung gehabt dann
hätten unsere dienste auf daten und
netzwerke länger als ein halbes jahr
will hat man einen anderen mann aber
anders finden können wie wir wissen
durch den untersuchungsausschuss der bei
also zu sagen netz der ermittler dass
alle männer haben waren gefallen ihre
befugnisse auch teil des themas weil man
natürlich auch die netzwerke nicht so
aufklären konnte und ich will nur auch
noch mal sagen nicht dass da der falsche
eindruck entsteht ich glaube es gibt
auch keinen grund sich für 2015 soweit
zu schämen zu sagen wir wollen nicht
humanität sondern wir wollen nur härte
beides gehört glaube ich zusammen aber
deswegen dürfen wir uns jetzt auch da an
der stelle nichts vormachen und was mich
so ein bisschen stört ist dass das
richtige ziel von humanität daneben oft
von den leuten ausgenutzt wird den wir
gegenüber toleranz anbringen die im
traum aber nicht gestehen ich
widersprechen ich würde eher sagen die
union könnte sich dafür schämen wieder
an die flüchtlinge integriert wurden ich
habe meiner cover reporterin war ich
mein friedlich sein es war jetzt schon
mal sehr es war 2017 und für mich war
das ganz schrecklich und das hat
übrigens auch meine sich komplett damals
auch die flüchtlingskrise geändert am
anfang war ich aus nahm gesagt auch die
grenzen sollen wir müssen mehr dicht
machen danach habe ich nicht mehr so
gesehen ich frage mich eher warum nicht
eine bessere integration gelungen ist
manche anbieter wie zb einer davon war
gab sehr viele früher damals die haben
ja über 3000 euro pro flüchtling von der
bundesregierung kommen und dafür an die
flüchtlinge der wirklich gehaust und wo
überhaupt nicht integration
wenn wir diesen fachkräftemangel haben
und so das müssen wir da ran aber
eigentlich darf man dabei nicht einfach
nur daher reden und sagen na ja man muss
ja abschied man müsse abschieben wo soll
ich denn solche leute hin abschieben die
aus afghanistan mit welchen flugzeugen
bringe ich die dahin da ist natürlich
sind uns da die hände gebunden muss man
ja nicht wieder reißt
nicht ab auch da realistisch sein und
nicht einfach kluge sprüche machen nach
dem motto du musst alle wieder zurück
gebracht wenn ein und da wo ich müsste
nur bei den zustrom gerade aus dem grund
weil uns völlig klar ist und das finde
ich es auch für eine partei die szenen
namen hat eben auch klar dass wir nicht
mitten in bürgerkriege abschieben in
nicht humanitäre situation das gehört
immer dazu überlassen hat so ist
deswegen können wir nicht in
unbegrenzten zustrom haben sondern
müssen den regionen aber dann lassen sie
doch mal konkret bleiben was ist denn
mit den flüchtlingen die jetzt werde
über das thema gesprochen aus
weißrussland über polen immer mehr nach
deutschland ja was sollten wir dass er
sich mir da gibt es jetzt einen sehr
unterschiedlichen streit wenn man in das
ampel sondierung papier schaut werden
die für den sogenannten spurwechsel da
fragt man sich was ist das eigentlich
der spurwechsel soll dafür sorgen dass
die über das ticket asyl kommen
sozusagen in die erwerbs million steigen
können dann im zweifel
integrationsleistungen bekommen und das
finde ich in der pauschalität wie es
teilweise gefordert wird nicht richtig
sondern ich finde wer illegal in das
land eingereist der muss dann im zweifel
wenn es rechtlich möglich ist auch
wieder zurückgeführt werden und ich
finde die trennung die wir eigentlich
haben zwischen humanitärer migration
über das asylrecht und zwischen
fachkräfte einwanderung diese trennung
ist sinnvoll und ich habe große sorgen
dass die immer weiter aufgeteilt werden
soll das ist politik der grünen auch in
der letzten wahlperiode gewesen und ich
glaube das wird nur noch mehr dazu
führen dass die leute sagen hauptsache
erstmal nach deutschland kommen und dann
klären da schon dass wir irgendwie einen
bleibe grund behalten das kann nicht
richtig sein
diese erkenntnis hat ein bisschen
gedauert wir erinnern uns ja an die
wirkliche bekämpfung wenn ich dann
roland koch denke wer sich auch wieder
zu wort meldet von einwanderungsgesetze
und entsprechenden vorhaben aber
immerhin dass sie das zu sehen spricht
ja für sie wir brauchen klare regeln was
die einwanderung möglich macht wir
werden einen immensen fachkräftemangel
haben und dieser spurwechsel auf den sie
angesprochen haben heißt doch nicht dass
jeder asylbewerber ihr in arbeit in lohn
und brot kommt wenn er abgewiesen wird
sondern es heißt es wenn dann ordner
schreiner dabei ist dass der auch seine
arbeit machen soll wenn du aber da
müsste doch endlich mal darüber reden
darüber wird mir viel zu wenig in der
gesellschaft gerät wie schaffen wir die
integration also man kann ja wohl nicht
sagen ich weiß nicht die
flüchtlingsheime heute sind aber wenn
die sind wie sie 2017 war ich ehrlich
sagen da würde ich auch kriminell werden
wenn was passiert ein einziger fall ein
einzelfall aber ich glaube es ist nicht
ein einzelfall ein unternehmer hat den
flüchtlingen weil sich arbeiten
ausbildung hat er da gemacht der super
gut war am ende ist er gegangen warum
war in dem heim irgendwie angeworben
wurde von irgendwelchen jungs in einer
der lieber scheiße gebaut weil das geld
auch brauchte ich frage mich warum
unsere integration nicht wirklich
probiert den leuten deutsch beizubringen
und sie auch zu
großes thema